leur départ par rapport à l'histoire
ils n'étaient pas très nombreux et les
gens ont commencé à chasser ensemble
donc la chasse c'est un dénominateur
commun des calédoniens
aujourd'hui quand je parle de caledonia
je vous parle de tout le monde est
aujourd'hui menacée tout vent qui se
retrouvent sur les terrains de chasse
c'est un trait culturel partagé c'est
presque un signe identitaire
je crois que on est profondément attaché
à cette terre
on a toujours l'impression d'être sur
cette terre et puis de tout maîtriser de
tout contrôler faut pendre une chose
c'est que c'est elle qui nous pend
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
j'ai même mouvement
[Applaudissements]
donc patrick 1p cet animal il ya environ
une heure et il vient de la porter sur
la scène voilà donc je voudrais d'abord
remercier avant de commencer le
propriétaire qui nous a permis d'avoir
cette fête c'est monsieur yvon craignez
donc une personnalité bien connue à
boulouparis et qui tous les ans offre
gracieusement des animaux qui sont
présentés pour être dépouillés de leur
public ligne donc la première chose
qu'il fait c'est super les pattes pour
pouvoir dégager le corps
voilà donc les avants qui sont mis à la
poubelle et maintenant il va attaquer
les arrières donc vous préparez un cerf
on commence par les postérieurs et non
on va lever au pouvoir le dépouiller de
façon perpendiculaire ans c'est vrai
c'est barbare il ya du son ben voilà ça
fait partie malheureusement de la
réalité des choses
bien sûr si on pouvait s'en passer on
s'empresserait va donc patrick
maintenant on va enlever la pression
c'est pas une démonstration bord
c'est tout simplement une partie de
notre vie voilà c'est comme ça qu'on vit
à boulemane merci pathétique
[Musique]
alors l'académie c'est un pays on chasse
depuis depuis toujours parce que c'est
un pays qui est grand est un pays qui
est vide
donc ça veut dire beaucoup d espace
c'est un pays où on a introduit des
manifs air au xviiie siècle
non je dis une connerie c'est pour le
même succès 19e à la fin du 19e siècle
on a introduit du cers on a introduit du
cochon sauvage dans le but de fournir
des protéines aux populations et
aujourd'hui en france hier voilà donc si
on chasse en calédonie vinci pour manger
tout simplement c'est pour se nourrir ni
chasse alors pratiquement toute la
population toutes les toutes les couches
techniques sociales culturelles de la
population chasse mais la grande
majorité chasse
pour se nourrir et la grande majorité ce
sont les mêmes des petits calédoniens de
toutes origines des kanaks et caldoches
des tahitiens dévoile des javanais des
gentilles et des métropolitains tous ces
gens là bon pratiquer la chasse pour le
plaisir bien sûr le dossier pour pouvoir
manger du bon gibier
les plus sur la scène
la tête dans les nuages
voir les bois
je n'ai pu
[Musique]
oh
et de couleurs
que j'ai grandi c'est sur ses terres
[Musique]
tu vois un petit senti que la battue
elle va passer commande motrice emmanuel
magne et c'est toi qui te l'a pas dit
oui tu fais en venant comme ça j'ai donc
qui fait cliché qui nous prévient qu'on
s'est terminée en général c'était dans
les propriétés privées avons eu beaucoup
moins de serveurs
maintenant bon blessure ça sa plume mais
avant il y avait moins de serre donc des
propriétaires terriens garder les serbes
pour eux quoi pour des chasses avec des
amis quelques amis qui arrivé le week
end être comme ça il tuer un cerf ou de
serre alors que maintenant avec ces
grandes chances ça a permis de faire
chasser beaucoup plus de monde ensemble
beaucoup plus de bon n'est vraiment de
tout de toutes sortes quoi de toute
catégorie qu aussi bien des gens de
nouméa de tous les villages
notre monde partout quoi on avait des
gens ni athée qui sont venus samedi
dernier c'est vraiment c'est loin ils
sont venus quand même koumac et ils sont
venus et ils étaient enchantés et nous
ont demandé quand est ce qu'ils ont et
la prochaine battue et ils sont prêts à
revenir à beaucoup je pense oui et on ça
crée des liens ça on fait connaissance
avec beaucoup de gens mais moi je
connaissais pas beaucoup de monde je
restais dans le fond de la chaîne je
connaissais personne et maintenant je
connais des centaines de personnes
allez on va dire il ya 130 entre 130 et
150 mètres moi j'utilise pas de télé m
parce que bon après on a l'habitude et
puis comme on tire la barre du coup par
rapport à la hauteur la barre à la barre
elle est suffisamment longue dont mais
même si la balle est un petit peu plus
bas où un petit peu plus + hôtel est
dedans quoi ce qu'il faut pas tirer sur
tout c'est la tête quoi parce que bon la
tête on peut casser la mâchoire et puis
un bétail une bête qu à la mâchoire
cassée c'est hard pour elle quand même
parce que elle va mourir dans d'atroces
souffrances
et puis bon il ya un truc bien quand
même c'est que maintenant quand on
récupère les mouchoirs les gens ils
tirent plus dans les têtes parce que les
mâchoires elles ont une valeur lala
actuellement il ya deux balles de tirer
il ya deux bêtes parce que là tu l'as
l'autre la balle qu'on a entendu elle
est la porte et voilà il a probablement
cassé une barre du coup aussi parce
qu'avec le bruit on on arrive on arrive
à savoir par rapport à l'impact sur
quelles parties de l'animal en tire quoi
ça peut ça peut surprendre mais en fait
bon on tire tellement d'animaux et
depuis depuis tellement longtemps que
l'oreille elle est éduquée à tout ce à
quoi on travaille avec tous nos sens
quoi voilà ça on dit c'est les pattes ça
c'est une méthode qui viennent nos
voisins il vous est demandé et
australiens donc voilà une poignée
mais pas toujours vers l'extérieur on
pas gêné pour porter parce qu'après
quand on porte ça faut pour que le
flingue ou avec des fois y'a le sac des
fois il ya d'autres choses à porter
voilà pas tu es tu portes voilà c'est
bon c'est pas trop y voilà 6e les mains
pour pas mal de sons sur le flanc gauche
et puis voilà la ravine
allez c'est bon
faut quand même pas oublier que ce qu'on
fait là c'est quand même le dessert pour
l'avion quand même talent on n'est pas à
la recherche d'un exploit si léger ton
qu'on est tout simplement bas dans un
acte de notre vie pour la vie des gens
qui sont en bon choix voilà donc c'est
un petit bonheur la balade des ballades
où il avait cédé ou c'était dans le fixe
voilà mais ils ont tiré combien de coups
de fusil aux autres là bas 1
après quoi c'est pas des thunes est
scellée qui loupe qui tient un cd du dos
et quand même ils ont dit on va enlever
tous les yeux chers pour mettre dcf 9,1
à la lui tient modou lô a décidemment le
jury était au fond de la vallée
c'est dans le fond de la valise c'est
une association de chasseurs tout
simplement on a réuni tous les chasseurs
qui aimait la chasse aux gens des
villages des tribus de même quelle que
soit d'ailleurs aussi on est ouvert à
tout le monde tous ceux qui aiment la
chasse surtout le serv écho chez soi
photo le circuit cochons sauvages dans
l'association
après bon ben il ya d'autres chasseurs
souvent mais a pressé ses personnels
après ils chassent des fois les on sait
peu mais tout ça c'est un partage c ca
partage
on les entend là bas qu'ils partagent
d'ailleurs si on veut avoir un bon saut
alors qu'un doute le plus important
c'est la préface la chasse c'est
important un
mais l'après chasse je crois que c'est
aussi important pour un chasseur qui
adore la chasse qui aiment que ça c'est
important
mais après il va se retrouver dans une
âpre et chasse qui est vachement super
ça le fera revenir ça c'est sûr il va
chercher à retrouver seignal c'est sûr
il ya des liens entre les communautés
ben je sais pas je vois pas de
communauté c'est une communauté puis ça
s'arrête là c'est des chasseurs voilà
c'est on en voit qu'une deux communautés
pour moi destin commun aa je crois qu'il
va commencer on entend ça a commencé
quand j'étais petit mon père j'étais
chasseurs quand mais je vis si on
connaît ça fait que ben je le suivais
partout
tous les samedis on était à la chasse
porter un marché j'aime bien tout dans
la chasse est là
la prochaine j'aime bien aussi quand il
s'agit de dépouiller les cercles les
portes et tout ça et le repas aussi
ouais c'est bien parce que enfin quand
grudge ans et puis on se fait des
connaissances penser beaucoup d'amis
aussi le poids on faisait la battue
comme sa tu appuies labatut on est
habitués on la connaît par coeur on la
connaît par coeur séoul et séraphine pas
c'est tout ça à pire on sait à chaque
fois comment on se fait avoir par les
serbes
comment je fais baiser quoi tu as donc
on est là voilà donc on avance comme ça
puis on arrive on a non à tan tan tan
tan tan tan tan mais on a on arrive
enfin en bas tu vois on arrive enfin bac
et puis moi je suis dans l'eau comme sa
pige à christophe et christophe tu vois
les mecs combat puis tu vois avec jules
parce que à chaque fois laissé à fives
ont ils se mettent sous les bourreaux
il ya toujours un troupeau de serbes qui
se met sous les boues raout pour juste
avant de sortir sur les postes alors le
mec il balancé l'information à jules et
dit ouais jules ok c'est bon tu peux
avancer
tu fais bien attention resserré bien la
ligne parce que tous les servent
ils sont sur le bourg à eau on va encore
se faire bananer et julie dit non non
non pas de problème pas de problème j'ai
bien compris j'ai bien compris et tout
ça c'est bon on y va et les mets qui
partent tous tu as été un moment après
moi d'en haut je vois les mecs y avons
joué à jules puis je vois tout le
troupeau de cf qui repart dans le sens
contraire et au moins qu'un servent qu à
et puis à ce moment là le directeur de
chasse qui appelle jules qui disait
jules et julie dit ouais on va encore se
faire mal on rit beaucoup et c'est vrai
c'est vrai que d'autres dans d'autres
activités aussi mais c'est vrai qu'à la
chasse rapport aux situations
rencontrées
il ya beaucoup de situations qui sont
burlesque d'autres parfois hélas qui le
sont moins mais qui génère toujours un
con tre regard de la part des chasseurs
qui sont là où des nous même les non
chasseurs qui sont là et et ça c'est
quelque chose de deux traits calédonien
cette capacité à tourner en dérision les
choses les plus graves
[__] il est beau bien gras cette foire
du mot de l'autre un ca voilà c'est des
petites histoires comme ça qui est bon
qu'ils qui nous font bien rire et qui
sont resservis à chaque fois à chaque
fois bon il y en a des nouvelles on a
des anciennes
voilà il ya une fois il ya un type qui a
attiré dans un troupeau de serre mais le
type là particulièrement c'était aussi
ici on a un an pour ça les gens les gens
qui chassent et qui sont un peu énervés
on les appelle les fusils sauteurs les
fusils sauteurs et donc
le type a balancé une rafale de coups de
fusil dans le troupeau de servent bien
sûr mon troupeau est parti et on arrive
sur lui et on me diallo
qu'est ce que tu as fait j'ai tiré comme
en congé tirer commun consiste à mettre
en place en un temps non remy 3 par
terre et tous etc
ouais mais les ballons portés et là il
ya un gars qui dit oui j'ai entendu une
balle portée et ont dit aux gars mais tu
as bien entendu la balle
tapez la tabbee entendu la balle et well
as bien tapé mais elle a tapé un q7
comme si elle cassé un os coin est bon
il ya un troupeau peut-être de quinze 15
20 m ensemble quoi donc on est allé à à
peu près 1
120 mètres de là où l'équipe avait tiré
et on a commencé à regarder par terre
pour avoir des indices sur sur l'animal
touchés et ben là on regarde et on
trouvait pas de sens on trouvait pas de
sens et puis d'un seul coup mais y en a
et d'entre nous qui accueillait les mecs
regardez ce que j'ai trouvé et là il a
ramassé la queue d'un certes il a trouvé
la clé d'un servent donc le qui paraît
quand même réussi dans dans sa danse à
rafale de coups de fusil à couper la
queue du cf on n'a jamais revu le serbe
qui n'avait pas de queue mais chaque
fois qu'on va à cet endroit on dit
toujours la f1 si tu vois un servent
qu'à pattes que tu le tir passait le cfa
intel alors c'est lui qui va le idoine
finir faut qu'il le retrouve quoi voilà
c'est ça un peu l'humour de la chasse
locale kgo mais je crois que ton humour
qu'on retrouve un peu partout
[Musique]
tous les tickets d'un principalement
quand on en a mais enfin on en a besoin
bon pour pour nos activités pour nos
activités sur la propriété ça nous ça
nous a déjà nous déplacer à emmener de
l'engrais penser à des endroits
difficiles et puis en plus gros surtout
pour la chasse ça me sert ça nous sert
pour la pour la fasm tout helvea est
obligé d'avoir impliqué pour déplacer
comme ne serait ce que pour aller on est
les seuls si on a une voiture un peu
partout
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le lieu dit s'appelle js j est
pourquoi ben je ne sais trop rien moins
que je suis née s'appelait js ça a
commencé ici c'est les premiers colons
feuillet prespa miss arrivé ici est à
colonisation fut bien avant de
s'installer à boulouparis s'installer à
js il y avait une école de l'église est
très famille le bordel
[Musique]
ce matin on a inventé le bétail commencé
tous les mois autres étaient
principalement là on a traité on avait
remis sujet et en même temps c'est un
produit qui fait l'hévéa et l'éthique
on continue on continue à travailler
parce que m mais d'abord je veux pas
encourager ma fille a fait ça parce que
c'est un métier de con ya pas de samedi
a pas de dimanche il n'y a pas de repos
c'est jusqu'à l'amour qu'on doit et puis
la retraite ou même pas y compter elle
ne lui en a pas de voter le seul jeune
gauche comme le fils à paul dedrick lui
oui mais en train de se faire sa
propriété mais sinon dans notre société
et même en faire un lotissement mais
beaucoup de filles dans l'est dans la
poche au départ été repris ont regardé
les vies en face je voudrais pas j'ai
juré sur le lean mort de mon grand père
mon père de ne jamais on vous imagine
quand j'avais 10 12 ans y ont tué deux
trois soeurs dans la liste et le bout du
monde alors on s'est dit avec les
propriétaires à côté monsieur m6 le
crosnier on peut tuer les biffle et le
résultat est là c'est que maintenant bas
c'est l'invasion tout ce qu'ils font
comme du beurre au bain nouveaux
pâturages
si on n'est pas en touriste même pas la
peine de planter sinon on retrouve toi
la terre car rien qui pousse même déjà
quand c'est des endroits le pic que le
monde a été chercher le bétail
avance-t-elle ronde d'entraînement
grand-père les mimosas était partie la
tp il fallait trois jours vous sentez le
bétail de là haut
maintenant c'est un désert ils ont tous
fait crever
[Musique]
oui
on
[Musique]
on va se laisser porter on verra bien
à
il était
histoire de violence
mais sans manquer
enfants
ja
num
[Musique]
coli
les grands-parents ont exploité une
propriétaire canada un negro pou il
faisait du café et dès qu'on pouvait
monter en monter là haut
donc on passait les vacances là haut et
on était dans un bain
dans un bagne famille calédonienne avec
beaucoup d'enfants tout ça c'était
dirigé par une grand-mère qui chassent
et qui faisait la cuisine qui s'occupait
d'eux
de tout et c'est un mandat par quoi
c'était c'était une vie comme comme la
plupart des gens sur les propriétés mais
il y avait quand même quelque chose de
clanique dans tout ce à quoi on était
les gens de cet endroit il y avait les
kanaks qui étaient là bien sûr mais par
rapport à l'histoire d'un endroit où on
est et voilà c'était chez cannelle qu'il
perde cannelle mais ça voulait dire tous
ces gens là quoi donc il y avait pas mal
de gossip avec les cousins il y avait
des cousines il y avait les frères les
soeurs il y avait des amis il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants et donc les
vacances c'était la café riz concédée la
saison du café bahamas et le café avec
la grand-mère
et puis c'était la chasse aussi et la
chasse était essentiellement les concept
parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup de mousse
est à cet endroit là il est pas mal de
nids dans la vallée la chasse de la
roussette à cette époque les cartouches
ce n'était pas comme maintenant les gens
n'avaient pas d'argent pour acheter des
cartouches donc on ne brûlait pas des
cartouches comme ça pour qu'il y avait
sur
sur des animaux quand on tirait sur un
animal c'est fait pour tuer pour le
manger
donc il y avait cette notion ben voilà
il faut tirer une cartouche pour avoir
un animal
donc on descendait dans la caf et rit on
se mettait
à la nuit au pied d'un pommier kanak ou
d'un autre arbres fruitiers ou un
gagnant ou de concept venaient manger et
là on attendait on attendait les rues
cette tournée on les entendait volet on
y voyait tourner quand elle se pose et
ben voilà la grand mère
la grand-mère éclairé et puis et puis
tiré mais c'est aussi surtout dans la
chasse dans la chasse et je crois que
c'est peut-être une des notions les plus
plus intéressante
j'ai jugé que j'ai eu moi qui m'a été
transmise
c'est cette notion d'atteinte de
contemplation nous on est dans
l'obscurité parfois noir à toutes les
angoisses qu'on peut imaginer
en attendant que quelque chose se passe
le monde
vous passez des gros coups - bull est
installée ici
au début on fait une haie groupe aubin
malheureusement mais bon c'est
l'histoire qui est comme ça ben des
groupes o ça s'est terminé au mois de
mai 88 au moment des événements c'était
100 je crois que
cette maison c'est cette maison dont je
parlais tout à l'heure cette maison n'a
vécu tout ça elle a brûlé au mois de mai
[Musique]
là
et ça
je suis sans compter tous s'amuser
qui sait
g
et chasser
[Musique]
tout le
pouvoir la voir
je n'ai plus d'un
leurs déboires
[Musique]
un peu
je
la chasse c'est un instrument du destin
commun luc laërt
c'est une pratique qui permet à chacun
de le montrer
son vrai visage je crois que on ne peut
pas être plus vrai que lorsqu'on est
dans une situation où on est en face
d'un animal et qu'on va lui ôter la vie
et quand on est avec d'autres personnes
les gens ne voient dans cet état là
[Musique]
on
et
[Musique]
vous savez tandem berceau natal déjà
bout ça même si j'étais fonctionnaire
j'ai voulu revenir dans ce berceau parce
que c'est ma vie c'est c'est ma joie
c'est mon bonheur et je dirige mes
enfants un peu dans cette optique là
parce que ça peut être un plus malgré
l'emploi qu'on peut avoir mais on peut
toujours gérer ça au mieux c'est un
métier très dur
c'est un métier très dur il faut vouloir
surtout dans l'est notamment à mettant
dans la vallée tennis et j'estime un
petit peu que on est un peu les
pionniers de la vallée pour tous
développés il n'y a pas de réseau
électrique il n'y a pas de réseau
d'adduction douilles
il faut tout innover il faut tout vers
les ennemis au pouvoir
[Musique]
on éclate la peau est un gaillard voyez
celui là et ses peluches pas très bien
on le constate parce que nous sommes en
lune montante et quand nous sommes en
lune montante
apparemment les gaillac ne sait plus pas
très bien ça peut bien à lire je pense à
35 35 kg 30 35 kg pour les a remis à
l'endroit de la réalisation de la
clôture donc quand vous avez préparé
votre lot de poteaux il faut les
acheminer sur place soit deux hommes
parce que c'est pas tout mécanisables
[Musique]
avant que
commence à réaliser des pâturages et
avant même que j'achète cette propriété
il y avait la propriété et est
démesurément chasser et c'est sûr qui
régule et revu les biens vous fait
découvrir il avait une chose ça revient
ouais
des fois quand il passe en bas il passe
encore que ça va les fatiguer maintenant
si tu veux que je me bats comme ça
[Musique]
très bon dans le dos rouge 1 salle d'eau
rouge battu ici je crois en la
maintenant là c'est à dire je vais
sauter à la rivière j'hésitais entre me
rouler dans la terre bien pour enlever
tout ça là mais tu vois le son comme ça
c'est bon c'est vrai ciel ça c'est crade
et tout ça c'est quand même contente
quand on est à la chasse on aime bien
plaisir c'est ça
des bouger quand même mouillé non
il a soufflé hockey à vélo
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé justement sur cette
propriété
le problème c'est qu'il s'était beaucoup
bon il y avait beaucoup de bruit avec
quelques cernes il n'y avait pas de
pâturage améliorée dès l'instant où j'ai
installé ses pâturages améliorer la
venue des cfl s'est fait d'une telle
manière dont ils m'ont envahi sa d'une
telle à une grande vitesse je vous
dirais ils m'ont détruit sa en trois ans
en trois ans à être peau de serpent peut
te détruire un pâturage complet
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon ça va j'ai hâte c'est de
grimper comme ça le cercle comme geely
comme si la jeep il était devant moi il
s'est levé il s'est levé mais quand il
s'est appuyé
j'ai trouvé qu'il monte id collait pas
ouais il déconnait pas d'anti cependant
j'ai l'impression qu'ils s'appuyaient
sur dumont il était dans les liens de la
fait ça j'ai tellement eu peur j'ai déjà
fait mon cas mon fameux khan et shehzad
aux narines vrai et je les ai vus au
dessus de ma tête comme ça j'ai fermé
les yeux plus attendue était sale et en
même temps j'ai poussé la sûreté bonbons
et deux coups sont partis et moi s'est
engagé le série mettant vie sur la terre
tapé tapé dans vos noms et c'est fou
mais c'est en parler tout seul des
balles dans la barre du coup les deux
chevrotine comme celui d'un côté de
l'autre
mais c'est pas ça mais il m'est tombé
sur la tête et je t'assure que j'étais
en soule
je voyais les étoiles une amie m'a mis à
moitié chaos mais ce n'est pas par le
parrain fait c'est par la peur mais
c'est la peur des 10 est à peu près sûr
le mec peut-être répondre par un mais c
est me suis peut-être le sol mais c'est
pas moi c'est lui qui a tiré tout seul
donc voilà qui met ça dans la colonne
vertébrale et sur samassa vadrot
éventuellement combiné à je vais lui
couper le courant à raymond
c'est la terre et il faut être du matin
au soir dans ce bon ben il ya des fois
des coups durs mais ça c'est pas un bébé
suis là là là dans les environs bref
cinq lots les milliards montant est à
part li nian vous faites quoi d'autre
mais je fais 1e patate tard au tout ce
qui est facile pour moi qu'avec deux
emplois là bas je ne peux pas m'occuper
tôt tous les autres pilotes comme je
fais pas je préfère faire ça comme ça
tout le temps pour le faire
et au milieu de tout ça il reste du
temps pour la chasse ah oui on trouve le
temps ni un moyen bon mais maintenant on
n'est pas tous les jours là ça fait
qu'on va pas tuer un sirh tous les jours
en faire quoi que l'avion nous aussi on
veut tous les jours on peut que 2/3
certes mais leur force il va falloir
qu'ils les détruisent et sert de moi je
connais des forêts avant on allait avec
l'herbe ici comme ça maintenant vous
allez c'est comme la terre peut-être car
il y en aurait cinq sites au nom de
jouer tout le monde me demande les
appels téléphoniques patate méridien et
puis il peut pas avoir deux 2 bras 2 au
mi6 et de la bataille n'est pas moi mais
j'ai dit ça ira mieux quand on va être à
la retraite
[Musique]
les plus anciennes talla sylla s'est
fait à bord
ça c'est pas glam de tous les maux dont
comportant même alors un peu mais ça
tient tassez le bon sens
[Musique]
les ignobles ça fait pas une tradition
en cas d'accident et moi je tutoie
manakara plus m'arrêter moi je me suis
consacré un terme à la culture vivrière
finalement lézignan je vois les miens
mais génial il ya les ignames pour
manger les animaux qui veut la coutume
et sa ligne ligne insalubre et au bras
canadien bat de lang lang c'est tout
c'est un peu le lieu où où les clans
sont ici là et ce en partie basse est le
peuple c'est de sa faute au temps pas
le chance pour nous c'est quelque chose
de lisse on d'igname surtout le
souligner c'est quelque chose de sacré
pour nous donc on a besoin de toujours
aller voir le show d'être en contact
avec elle
là où nous sommes là où le dessous nous
donc c'est comme un apport aux élèves on
a besoin de tendresse et de nous avons
besoin d'être là regardez le champ
pousser donc ça fait partie de mes
leçons d' ignoble c'est quelque chose
qui est présent tant au niveau de notre
culture à l'igname c'est l'homme et
c'est ça qu'on partage aux enfants pour
qu'ils puissent seller l'importance de
l'igname
des fois que les gens s'étaient moqués
par 200 pieds a à peu près lézignan que
j'ai ce que vous allez tous les deux les
petits as goûté c'est les semences pour
l'année prochaine les souffrances la
consommation je conserve si un des des
défaites ou des choses qui se passent de
la tribu voir rentrer un petit silence
et les petits ses coureurs c'est pour la
semence et pour les coutumes ses
desquels les coutures s'était appelé les
liens ma petite tête hawaï est bon il ya
un moment où ce n'est que les cochons
sont alliées ou détient pour même si
jamais il ya un problème parce que notre
son et image au tard et mal vu
le tubercule quoi rien et quand il m'a
le tubercule qu'une fois - images ont
presque à la maturité
qu'est ce que la maturité moyenne en
gêner et le problème des cochons ces
crétins le cadre de la rive d'un champ
et quand ils commencent à goûter
vous passez dans un champ vous voyez
d'autres viennent d'une yom qui sont
partis et si on arrive bas at il faut
chaud ou je ne sais pas mais finalement
cette fonction du bar de l'avenir de la
chasse à la fin c'est tout le monde je
dimanche à l'avenir de l'accalmie on
fera prendre on sait maintenant où on
pas changer tout d'un coup quelque chose
qu'on a tous n'est qu'une demi heure
bien sûr dans une vallée comme samba où
il y avait oui encore aujourd'hui
quelques européens
on arrive à vivre tous ensemble à côté
sur la mer oui donc ici a dit silvana à
tient là c'est qu'on trouve encore des
colons commune
donc ici on arrive à on arrive à
s'entendre
marie victorine par exemple les enfants
à elk dans les poteaux nous et le
porte-monnaie et ses enfants et porte le
nom de ma grammaire et de ma tante
donc c'est un peu faux di rupo des
internats il ya quelque chose qui
attendent s'est hissée d'ici et on peut
dire aussi que voilà le destin commun
c'est ça on le vit sur le tas on le
glisse
[Musique]
oh
des vallées
pour les mains se resserre
du marché
[Musique]
dieu m'en parler
les armes en vue placé
c'est dans mes yeux
scellant leur dieu
qu'il aimait
[Musique]
en fait le sentiment qu'on a depuis
depuis tous les tous les bouleversements
qu'a connues l'archipel
c'est un sentiment d'accélération tout
va très très vite
on est certainement une des dernières
générations de calédoniens à vivre ça ça
s'appelle la liberté et moi je
rajouterais même c'est une liberté qui
est luxueuse même si elle est déplié
même si très simple même si on n'a pas
l'impression d'être riche mais on est
riche de tout ce qui les entoure et
l'intérêt l'intérêt pour nous dans dans
cette démarche pour les gens qui tout
cas qui ont opté pour ce mode de vie
c'est une part de le vivre pleinement
mais aussi et surtout de le partager
puisque je crois que dans vous parlez de
temps parlé tout à l'heure de
de la chasse de la chasse partager en
fait si l'avis est partagé
[Musique]
et
sur la tête dans les nuages
cooper les bois
à genève plus loin
[Musique]
oh
colas
c'est
ce que j'ai produit
c'est sur ses terres
j'ai la vendée
[Musique]
à
l'histoire de violence
ce temps mon coeur
[Musique]
ce
entre nous
apparu à six
je vais ténue
oui
ok
par les corps
[Musique]
blain
c'est
s'engager sans compter celles des hommes
qui ont lutté
g
et chasser
[Musique]
tous là
pour les bois
les plus lâches
[Musique]
les bois
faux
allez
les mains sur st
vieux marché
il
vieux monde
vous avez passé
citant leurs dieux
que j'assume
[Musique]
les yeux